one-third of programmers using marijuana
while working with many touting
creative benefits study fines this is a
story
uh from uh the marijuana moment okay
uh researchers at university of michigan
said that the anecdotal evidence
suggested that those in programming were
more likely to use cannabis on the job
so they set out to conduct a first
large-scale survey on the topic this
provision of cannabis used in software
engineering has contributed to a widely
reported hiring shortage for certain u.s
government programming jobs the study
finds 53 said they've consumed cannabis
while working and programming at least
12 times 27 percent said they use it at
least twice a week and four percent say
they use it while working on a daily
basis okay
good thing bad thing funny story who
cares where are you at with this i'll
tell you where i'm at with this
and speaking from experience from
creative benefits when i was in my
stand-up comedy days i did two things
three things all day every day i would
smoke weed and when i was living in
denver
i would write jokes half of them were
absolutely ridiculous half of them i
used on stage i would
then go play basketball in the afternoon
in the mile high city literally and uh
and then i would go do stand up at night
and it really does help
your creative
juices flow the problem with that is
though you know you smoke your weed and
then like three hours later you're like
it's time for a nap it's like dude it's
noon what are you doing so there are
creative benefits for it but the
downside is you lose energy you lose
stamina you lose your ability to like
keep going and and
somebody that maybe has experience david
what do you think about that
no joke uh i have a friend his name is
i was doing sound design for this film
and i mean he was doing sound design for
this film
and he got really high and he thought it
was dope and then he sent it and the guy
was like hey buddy uh was this like a
first draft or something this sounds
like dog [ __ ] it was terrible so it
doesn't make you creative you've set up
everything but programming uh i don't
think you would do that well by the way
we'd love to meet schmidt yeah one of
you yeah he's super busy though
am i the only one that thought one-third
was like low yeah
i think it's like way more well what
percentage of americans do you think
have smoked weed oh a lot dude i'm
actually probably one of the only one of
my friends that doesn't like weed like
i've never in my i swear to god but you
do like the munchies that's my dude
that's the whole thing i've never needed
any ambition to be lazy and hungry in my
life i've got lazy and hungry covered
have you ever smoked weed i don't need
any help and what did it do for you
because you're the type of person that
does not need cocaine i was schmidt
you're going regardless
uh i can promise you yeah uh i have to
there's nothing about cocaine that does
me good because if you cut my blood
there's probably some cocaine there but
yes natural
assyrian uh uh
uh sugar that's gonna be in there no you
know wheat was
never smoked in high school never smoked
in the military i got out i uh
was dating this girl she was my boss and
one night we smoked weed and
i finished three bowls of berries
like literally i finished three bowls of
berries at night at one o'clock in the
morning that's the only story i remember
and it's probably very good for a guy
like me you serious you guys would
benefit from me smoking weed even though
i think at the end of the day when you
do smoke
man is it even still a big deal anymore
like if you found out sometimes
well i think a lot they came out they
said a large percentage i don't say a
large percentage a lot of companies have
done away with drug tests they should
they're just like come to work we need
you biz doc for someone that smokes weed
every day what do you think of this
story
um excuse me
well first of all david thank you for
not saying your friend's last name no
one will figure out who this guy is yeah
there's the only guy in south florida
with the name but um
no i think um you look at it
you look at who's in the dispensaries
you look at the people that are going
into in the interview you're finding
people you have to remember the people
that were high at woodstock what are
they now that's 1969 they're in charge
of our government they're the baby
blacks yes they're 80 years old they're
75 to 82 years of boomers and so you've
got people all the way up to that age
remembering this and i've always felt
that if you're going to legalize this we
need to regulate it paraquat hurt a lot
of people it was a pesticide that was in
it if you're going to legalize it then
let's make it like any food product or
ingesting product let's put some
standards on it but let's also figure
out a way to make sure if you're driving
completely stoned and putting people at
risk we can test for that and so
i have always felt if we're going to
legalize it let's legalize it the whole
way and let's also protect ourselves and
people how do you test for for driving
stones well there's already i mean
driving impaired is already a law so i
mean it's that is a law but it is a law
but reliable tests for
sure but even right now where it's
decriminalized in california there's
still a black market because the taxes
are so high they're asking for the taxes
to come down in california because the
drug dealers are still selling dime bags
for you know for 10 bucks so i'll tell
you a quick story
i'll tell you a quick story about
driving stoned and this is what i
realized dude don't be smoking and
driving over here i went first i
shouldn't be driving period yeah that's
great i agree i agree i should not be
trying yeah why don't you i've had a car
in 10 years i was 22 years old getting
the carrier thing and let the cat drive
thank you i was 22 years old and i
remember
i did not smoke all throughout high
school and in college and i was like i'm
a drug free i'm an athlete and then i
got i was playing college football and
all my teammates were getting stoned and
and doing all sorts of nonsense but this
one day i went to get in my car i was i
had to go run some errands and i get my
car and i go to put the key in the
ignition and i'm sitting in shotgun
i'm sitting in the passenger seat in my
car so they're you know you just brought
up a great [ __ ] so when i was when i was
don't be driving
folks he's just trying to make this up
this happens every week okay this is not
20 years ago this was last week but
what's crazy is like i think we all
agree like as far as like
drugs are concerned
it's pretty obvious at this point that
wheat is pretty low on the list of of
things that can like they call it what
is it a grade a what are they called or
whatever the dea whatever whatever they
can do to keep themselves in business
but the
the the the issue becomes you talked
about school
we'd stayed in your system for testing
for 30 plus days there wasn't like a
single athlete i knew that smoked weed
but instead we would do all the harder
[ __ ] the stuff that's way worse for you
because everything
24 hours yeah so it was like and dude
especially if you got injured if you got
injured or you were dealing with
soreness or something like that instead
of smoking weed you would you would take
oxies and you would take like pills that
are hardcore that have long you've
talked about this before i think we can
all agree that on the level of things
that people use
weed is way better for you than alcohol
or pills is it not but it comes out of
the ground it doesn't come out of a lab
so i mean it's there's profit incentive
for them to get kids hooked on on pills
that need prescriptions there's still
profit incentive in
in the greens though isn't there
well tax that week depends on on who's
who's in there but yeah i mean listen
what i think is interesting man is like
i told this to pat i'm not i'm not going
to say the guy's name david but i know a
guy who's a shmurard incredibly good
like 12 to 1600 a day editor for a major
network and he micro doses lsd the whole
day oh yeah well this is common
is it common micro dosing so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]